in this video i want to talk a little
bit about acceleration
acceleration and this is probably an
idea that you're somewhat familiar with
or at least you've heard the term used
here or there acceleration is just the
change in velocity over time change
in
velocity
over time probably one of the most
typical examples of acceleration if
you're at all interested in cars is that
many times they will give you
acceleration numbers especially for
sports cars actually all cars if you
look up if you look up in consumer
reports or wherever they give the stats
on different cars they'll tell you
something like i don't know like a a
porsche and i'm gonna make up i'm gonna
make up these numbers right over here so
let's say that we have a porsche 911
porsche 911 they'll say that a porsche
911 they'll literally measure it with a
stopwatch can go 0 to
60 miles per hour and these aren't the
exact numbers although i think it's
probably pretty close 0 to 60 miles per
hour in let's say 3 seconds
in
3 seconds
so although officially what they're
giving you right here are speeds because
they're only giving you magnitude in no
direction you can assume that it's in
the same direction i mean we could say
zero
zero miles per hour to the east to 60
miles per hour to the east in three
seconds so what was the acceleration
here so i just told you the definition
of acceleration it's change in velocity
over time so the acceleration and once
again acceleration is a vector quantity
you want you want to know not only how
much is velocity changing over time you
also care about the direction it also
makes sense because velocity itself is a
vector quantity needs magnitude and
direction so the acceleration here
and we're just going to assume that
we're going we're going to the to the
right 0 miles per hour and 60 miles per
hour to the right so what is that it's
going to be change in velocity so let me
just write it down with different
notation just so you can familiarize
yourself if you see it in a textbook
this way so change in
change in velocity
this delta symbol right here just means
change
change in change in velocity over time
over time and it's really as i've
mentioned in previous videos it's really
time is really a change in time
but we could just write we could just
write time here this three seconds is
really change in time it might have been
it might have been uh you know if you
look at your second hand it might have
been five seconds when it started and
then it might have been eight seconds
when it stopped so it took a total of
eight of three seconds so time is really
a change in seconds but we'll just go
with the time right here so or just with
the t
so what's our change in velocity so our
final velocity is 60 miles per hour our
final velocity is 60 miles per hour and
our original velocity was zero miles per
hour so it's 60 minus zero
miles per hour
miles per hour and then what is our time
what is our time over here well our time
is or we could even say our change in
time
our change in time is three seconds
three
seconds so this gives us 20 miles per
hour
per
second let me write this down so this
becomes this top part is 60. 60 divided
by 3 is 20. so we get 20 but then the
units are a little bit strange we have
miles instead of writing mph i'm going
to write miles
miles per hour
more hour that's the same thing as mph
and then we also in the denominator
right over here have we also right over
here in the denominator have
seconds which is a little bit strange
and as you'll see the units for
acceleration do seem a little bit
strange but if we think it through it
actually might make a little bit of
sense so miles per hour and then we
could either put seconds like this or we
could write per second
per second and let's just think about
what this is saying then we could get it
all into seconds or we could all get
into hours whatever we like this is
saying that every second this porsche
911 can increase its velocity by 20
miles per hour so its acceleration is 20
miles per hour per second and actually
we should include the direction because
we're talking about vector quantities so
this is to the east so this is east
and then this is east right over here
just so we make sure that we're dealing
with vectors we're giving it you're
giving it a direction due east so every
second it can increase in velocity by 20
miles per hour so hopefully the way i'm
saying it makes a little bit of sense 20
miles per hour per second that's exactly
what this is talking about now we could
also write it like this this is the same
thing as
miles
per
hour because if you if you take
something and you divide it by seconds
that's the same thing as multiplying it
by one over seconds so that's miles per
hour
hour seconds
and although this is correct to me this
makes a little less intuitive sense this
one literally says it every second it's
increasing in velocity by 20 miles per
hour 20 miles per hour increase in
velocity per second so that kind of
makes sense to me here it's saying 20
miles per hour seconds so
once again it's not let as intuitive but
we can make this so it's all in one unit
of time although you don't really have
to
you can change this so that you get rid
of maybe the hours in the denominator
and the best way to get rid of an hour
in the denominator is by multiplying it
by something that has hours in the
numerator so hour
and seconds
and here let's
the smaller unit is the seconds so it's
3600 seconds for every one hour or one
hour is equal to 3600 seconds or
one one thirty six hundredth of an hour
per second all of those are legitimate
ways to interpret this this thing in
magenta right over here and then you
multiply do a little dimensional
analysis hour cancels with hour and then
you have this will be equal to
this will be equal to 20 over 3 600
20 over 3 600
miles per seconds time seconds or we
could say
miles
let me write it this way miles
for seconds times seconds or we could
say miles per
second i want to do that in that another
color
miles per second squared
miles per
seconds
miles per second squared and we can
simplify this a little bit divide the
numerator and the denominator by 10 you
get 2 over 360
or you could get this is the same thing
as 1 over
1 over
miles
miles per second squared
per second squared i'll just abbreviate
like that and once again this doesn't
make you know 1 180th of a mile how much
is that you might want to convert it to
feet but the whole point in here is i
just wanted to show you that what one
how do you calculate acceleration and
give you a little bit of a sense what it
means and once again this right here
when you have second squared in the in
the bottom of your units it doesn't make
a ton of sense but we can
rewrite it like this up here this is
or 1 over 180
miles
per second
and then we divide by seconds again per
second
per second or maybe i could write like
this
per second
this is where this whole thing is the
numerator so this makes a little bit
more sense from an acceleration point of
view one over 180 miles per second per
second every second this porsche 911 is
going to go 100 1 180 of a mile per
second faster and actually it's probably
more intuitive to stick to the miles per
hour because that's something that we
have that we have a little bit of more
sense on and another way to visualize it
another way to visualize it if you were
to look at if you were to be driving
that porsche and you were to look at the
speedometer for that porsche
and if the acceleration was constant
it's actually not going to be completely
constant and if you looked at the
speedometer let me draw it so this would
be 10
60. this is probably not what the
speedometer for a porsche looks like
this is probably more analogous to a a
small four-cylinder car speedometer this
i suspect the porsche the speedometer
goes much beyond 60 miles per hour but
what you would see for something
accelerating this fast is right when
you're starting the speedometer would be
right there
and that every second it would be 20
miles per hour faster so after a second
it the speedometer would have moved this
far after another second the speedometer
would have moved this far and then after
another second the speedometer would
have moved that far and the entire time
you would have kind of been pasted to
the back of your seat